[Musique]
hong kong
dans ce restaurant de buenos aires on
cuisine pour environ 70 personnes chaque
jour
marcos a ouvert l'établissement il ya
trois ans et demi
là on à daniel qu'est en train de couper
du boeuf
si on propose surtout de la viande c'est
notre plus gros poste de dépense
en tant que chef d'entreprise il doit
toujours garder un oeil attentif au coût
de ces produits
d'autant plus qu'en argentine depuis le
début de l'année le prix des aliments
augmentent en moyenne de 6% tous les
mois
si on a des morceaux de cofinest ces
pièces là on les achète autour de deux
mille pesos
il ya moi on les paie et 1700
pour ne pas perdre d'argent il doit donc
modifier les prix à la carte très
régulièrement
ce qu'on essaie de faire c'est
d'actualiser un tout petit peu nos prix
toutes les semaines pour ne pas prendre
trop de retard sur la façon
on essaie de trouver le meilleur
compromis possible entre nos achats nos
ventes nos bénéfices commencent à vars
pacte et le prix
de la même façon le salaire de ses
employés doit être augmentée tous les
trois mois l'argentine a connu en effet
une désinflation les plus élevés au
monde elle pourrait dépasser les 70% en
dans ces conditions avoir un emploi ne
garantit pas toujours d'échapper à la
pauvreté
marilou qui travaille dans une
coopérative doit se rendre cinq fois par
semaine dans une soupe populaire pour
nourrir ses deux petites filles
la gambie c'est moi je vis seule avec
mes deux enfants on ne peut pas s'en
sortir avec les salaires qu'on reçoit et
l'inflation qui augmente tous les jours
on ne parle pas d'une inflation de 2%
mais bien plus élevé et mon salaire
reste le même donc c'est un problème
même
comme cette mère célibataire environ 200
personnes bénéficient quotidiennement
des repas préparés dans cette cuisine
associative de la banlieue sud de buenos
aires
malgré une demande grandissante
il est aujourd'hui impossible de nourrir
davantage de monde et
on est touchés par l'inflation les gens
viennent plus nombreux et nous demande
plus à manger
ce n'est pas qu'on ne veut pas leur
donner plus mais on n'a pas les moyens
de préparer davantage de repas
une situation de crise que la population
connaît bien
en 2001 l'état argentin faisait faillite
et se déclarer en défaut de paiement
les épargnants ont perdu toutes leurs
économies
depuis les manifestations n'ont jamais
cessé
le pays reste empêtré dans la dette et
l'inflation
la dette à
la dette du pays pèsent toujours sur nos
épaules le gouvernement a encore
contracté une dette en 2018 auprès du
fonds monétaire international
là on a signé un accord pour le
rembourser et ça a des répercussions
déjà qu'il n'ya pas de travail on a
aussi les prix qui augmentent
constamment
pour économiser leur argent malgré tout
les argentins qui en ont les moyens se
tourner vers une monnaie bien plus
stable le dollar
d'ailleurs en argentine les grosses
dépenses comme l'automobile ou
l'immobilier se font uniquement dans
cette devise
mais depuis plusieurs années il est
interdit d'acquérir plus de 200 dollars
par mois alors il existe des voies
parallèles
[Musique]
les gens qui veulent épargner en monnaie
étrangère vient ici pour changer leur
argent
comme on ne peut pas acheter plus de 200
dollars par mois il faut trouver
d'autres façons pour en obtenir
ce propriétaire d'un bureau de change
officieux dissimulés dans l'arrière
boutique d'une bijouterie nous répond un
visage masqué
car son activité est officiellement
interdite
en réalité tout le monde sait que ça
existe et personne ne peut l'empêcher
même des gens haut placés dans le
gouvernement achète et vend des dollars
dans ce genre de lieu
d'autres j'entends préfèrent se tourner
vers une alternative légale et sans
restriction très prisé dans le pays les
crypto monnaie
tous les mois ce groupe d'adeptes du
bitcoin se retrouvent pour échanger sur
les dernières tendances
geronimi ne vois pas de meilleur moyen
pour épargner son argent
en argentine on a l'habitude de ne pas
faire confiance aux banques elles nous
ont déjà confisqué notre épargne à
plusieurs reprises là je suis le seul
qui contrôle les bitcoins j'ai mon code
personnel et personne ne peut me les
confisquer
même si le cours des crypto monnaie est
très volatile la valeur de certaines
s'est même effondré ces derniers mois
elle reste pour ses utilisateurs
argentin toujours plus fiable que le
pesos elle fait confiance aux
mathématiques il y à un logiciel conçu
avec des règles qui ne changeront jamais
alors que pour une monnaie physique il
faut faire confiance aux politiques et
les politiques changent toujours les
règles
surtout dans un pays comme le nôtre où
les règles changent toutes les dix
minutes
ce soir le groupe pourra payer son
addition bitcoin d'après une étude
l'argentine serait le sixième pays au
monde où les monnaies virtuelles sont
les plus utilisées